non-minimalists
when you don't want to cling anymore
the journey to change can come with a
feeling of emptiness how do you deal
with that emptiness
so lisa emptiness we're dealing with
emptiness here and i suspect when you
walked away from comedy after 30 years
and now it was like okay i stopped
clinging to that the the question then
becomes what do i cling to next 100 like
okay cling to the idea of taking this
life coaching course for three years and
be a great hugely paid life coach having
a huge enormous podcast
getting to lead workshops like food
related workshops in krapalu or all
these yoga and meditation places canyon
ranch that'll make me happy so i started
clinging to those pursuits and then
again as i said before i was like none
of this is working none of it fills the
hole none of it makes me feel
at all peaceful it's just another rat
race in substitution for the comedy and
now it's like okay let's do nothing
and again i think it's just emptiness is
good because then it gives you space to
fill it with the right things and i
wasn't filling it with the right things
like connection and stuff real
connection right and you know by the way
dr drew i had said this on his podcast
this is so wild i said i don't think i
was ever a comic i think i was just
someone who was trying to connect with
something and that was the way i did it
and he was i suspect a lot of comedians
are like that yeah so yeah it don't work
don't be afraid of the emptiness i may
actually be afraid of it because it is
hard
but it won't last forever i think we
always are just thinking
if i start crying i'll never stop i'll
die from crying if i
have an emptiness an empty day it'll
never i'll never have another day with
something to do
and the saddest thing is not going to
the emptiness first yeah it makes me uh
makes me think about how it's almost a
superpower to be able to sit with
emptiness
and hold space for it because that's i
mean yeah sometimes there's a void
that uh that only you know you can fill
with acceptance of the void if that
makes sense yep yeah
right so the void that we often create
or other people create it for us whether
it's marketers or demographers or your
peer group
they make you feel inadequate but it's
really you that make you feel inadequate
so that emptiness the problem with the
emptiness is we presuppose that it needs
to be filled
right you buy a giant house you had four
homes lisa and of course it's not just
four empty homes
these are four homes now i have to fill
them with things you have a spare
bedroom i have to get everything that is
supposed to be in there and so we make
up all these shoulds you know i should
buy this i shouldn't buy that i should
do this i shouldn't do that i should eat
this i shouldn't eat that and all of a
sudden we're filling our life with
everyone else's shoulds everyone else is
your supposed to's
and no wonder we're so miserable
we
have
identified this emptiness
it's we're not happy and so how am i
going to be happy i'm only going to be
happy if i fill the emptiness well no no
the reason i'm unhappy the reason i'm
discontented is i think that i should
fill the emptiness in the first place
nothing wrong with filling it but what's
appropriate for me what is um
where do i want to go what i want to do
with this some of the most beautiful
spaces are really beautiful art museums
that are functionally empty right
now
i don't walk into the broad museum
downtown l.a and say oh my god who's
going to where are we going to fill this
empty space
no
it's just about appreciating the space
for what it is and maybe that emptiness
is a sign of calm of serenity with peace
that's big yeah you know what i'm very
proud of and you would be very proud of
this in my house my source of pride one
of them is that
i had
saved oh my mother's clothes the stuff i
saved was just kind of all these funky
old 90s sweaters that kids wear now
the youth of today and i know i have a
real hipster couple of nieces and
nephews so i gave them all and they were
thrilled they were like oh my god this
is so badass okay i kept those two
drawers empty
and every once in a while i look at them
and i go i don't have to fill these
drawers so it's really cool because then
i'm like whoa why do i have the dresser
so i can get rid of the dresser someday
maybe
maybe somebody needs that maybe one of
my my relatives or goodwill or um
habitat for humanity but it's so funny
to go oh i don't have to fill those now
that's a weird new feeling at 60 years
old that's like a literal acceptance of
the emptiness yeah cause maybe that
dresser because there are some beautiful
dressers and armoires and credenza i
mean there are some beautiful furniture
out there and maybe that makes the room
but yeah it doesn't mean that we have to
stuff it full of stuff just because we
have it there in the room i love that
it's the literal acceptance of emptiness
you're gonna laugh but i literally
sometimes go in that back room it's my
mother's old bedroom and i'll pull the
drawers open i'll be like yeah
i mean i know but it's learning what
the emptiness can do and we're just
afraid of external emptiness and
internal emptiness and it's just it's
okay we can all be scared but we can
kind of muddle through
and so maybe it's not empty maybe it's
merely clutter-free
did you enjoy this video if so you can
listen to full episodes of the
minimalist private podcast available
exclusively on patreon visit patreon.com
the minimalists today your support keeps
our podcast and youtube channel 100
percent advertisement free